[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
allô allô salut c'est qui c'est quoi tes
PIR jeux mais pire jeux pourquoi vous
voulez savoir ça ob sinon il va
t'arriver des choses horribles c'est une
blague non si c'était une blague
j'aurais dit B alors c'est deux œufs sur
une poê le premier dit pouf il fait
chaud et le deuxième répond oh mon dieu
qui oh mon dieu mais ce n'est pas une
blague oui non mais je veux dire ce
n'est pas une blague ce n'est pas drôle
oui ta gueule ta gueule maintenant tu
vas faire exactement ce que je te
demande jeux que tu
aambamb mais je dois faire quoi dans ma
chambreok tu vas aller dans ta
chambreoule pour
[Musique]
1 2 3 4
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh là là sérieux c'est inhumain ce que
je dois faire vraiment vous savez si
vous êtes déjà allé dans des magasins à
la recherche de jeux rétro vous avez dû
constater que les jeux sont maintenant
de plus en plus chers pourtant il existe
un type de jeu qui lui a gardé un prix
très bas parce que ce sont des jeux qui
ont très très mal vieilli c'est les jeux
de sport tout le monde a forcément joué
à ces jeux aussi mauvais qu'ils étaient
simplement parce que c'est c'est les
principaux jeux qui offraient la
possibilité de jouer à plusieurs que ce
soit des jeux de foot de tennis de
basket de jeux olympiques de tir ou peu
importe je a ce [ __ ] de chien celui
qui n'a jamais tiré dessus C
menteur
[Musique]
pou c'est un il est impossible de tuer
le chien dans sur nes pas la peine de me
spammer pour me demander comment j'ai
fait commençons par les jeux de foot est
un des premiers jeux de foot auquel j'ai
joué soccer voilà football tout
simplement on peut pas faire plus court
comme titre je veux dire c'est comme si
Call of Duty s'appelait pan
boou l'inertie de la balle à cette
époque est encore méga lourde on a
l'impression que les joueurs tirent dans
des boules de bouing mais bon ça la
limite c'est pas grave moi celui qui m'a
a bien fait hurler dans ce jeu c'est
lui qui est dans les cages sérieusement
gbert
montagier allez vas-y elle est sur toi
là sérieusement les cages sont
complètement vides on dirait que le
gardien se promène totalement au hasard
dans la surface et qu'éventuellement des
fois il est sur la trajectoire du ballon
ah là ça y est regardez là il est parti
faire un bisou à MAM dans les tribunes
d'ailleurs je crois que ce gardien plus
tard il est devenu arbitre aussi dans
Adidas powerer 98 un des seuls jeux de
FO je crois on pit littéralement
déboiter un mec qui avait pas la balle
sans faire de faute regardez-moi
[Musique]
ça allez on passe au basket avec NBA All
challenge en général quand j'achète un
jeu de basket je m'attends à PIR jouer
au basket mais pas ici en fait ce que je
savais pas avant d'acheter ce truc c'est
qu'ici on fait que des duels ou des
lancer francs yep c'est comme si tu
achetais un jeu de foot et que tu
faisais que des
[Musique]
touches même le public a l'air de crever
d'ennui et puis bon pourquoi est-ce que
des gens viendrai voir un mec pour tirer
des lancers franc je veux bien qu'on
rajoute la possibilité de faire des
duels ou des paniers en plus d'un jeu de
basket normal mais faire un jeu de
basket uniquement basé sur
ça temp qu'on est dans le basket parlons
de white man can't jump sur Jaguar alors
la Jaguar c'est déjà en soit une des
plus grosses arnaques de l'histoire des
jeux vidéos he cette console qui est
sortie en 93 a essayé de pénétrer le
marché avec ses 64 bit et
qui la Jaguar se présentait comme la
première console 64 bits alors tout le
monde se disait oh mon dieu mais elle
est quatre fois plus puissante que ma
Meg drive ou ma super N
c'est trop génial même si je sa pas ce
que c'est un B mais elle en a qu fois
plus white man C jump utilise un espèce
de mélange entre de la 3D et de la 2D en
essayant de faire passer ça pour des
graphismes révolutionnaires mais bon
comme dit ma mamie mettre du caca dans
une crêp n'en fait pas du nutella et
c'est pour ça que le résultat est
horrible et injouable et là vous pouvez
me croire quand je vous dis que c'est
totalement impossible d'évaluer les
distances avec ces graphismes je
comprends absolument rien à ce qui se
passe à l'écran ce jeu est tellement
mauvais qu'il aurait dû être interdit
par l'Église catholique je vous jure
j'ai pas de mots pour le décrire les
pixels sont anarchiques les contrôles
sont mauvais la caméra est dégueulasse
jouez à white man jump et vous aurez le
cancer c'est
tout mais évidemment c'est pas ces
jeux-là qui vous sont familiers quand on
vous dit vieux jeux de sport vous c'est
plutôt à ça que vous pensez Summer Games
World Games California Games
trackenfield et bien en fait tous ces
jeux viennent presque tous de la même
société etepx c'est le genre de jeu qui
est fait pour pour être joué avec des
amis mais où tu es arrivé jamais au bout
parce que tout le monde était gavé au
bout de 30 minutes et inventé n'importe
quoi pour rentrer chez lui California
game sorti en 1987 sur Master System oh
je veux pas y jouer j'aime pas les jeux
de sport je déteste le
sport pas le sport ça serait pas
de allez on commence par le skate
allez on commence par le
[Musique]
footbag est-ce que c'est possible de
faire un truc plus ennuyeux que
ça sérieusement mais c'est quoi c'est un
genre de simulation de mort cérébrale ce
jeu c'est quoi cette musique le musicien
il avait juste assez d'argent pour
acheter un C avec TR touches
[Musique]
dessus je peux pas m'empêcher d'avoir
pitié de ce mec là tout seul sur le
gazon vraiment il lui manque plus que la
pancarte pour avoir l'air encore plus
pathétique le Frisbey maintenant
ok non mais allez soyons sérieux je veux
dire même en étant très très très
mauvais au frisbe comment est-ce qu'on
pourrait rater un lancer à ce point-l
c'est
ridicule oh là là vous savez ce que je
déteste dans ces jeux c'est qu'on
t'explique rien on te lâche directement
dans le jeu et ça y est c'est tout
démerdeettoi toi pour trouver les
touches toi-même là il a fallu que
j'astique la manette pendant une heure a
essayer toutes les combinaisons les plus
bizarres possibles avant de trouver la
bonne il faut appuyer sur un pour
préparer le lancer appuyer sur gauche
pour bouger la barre puis sur droite
pour régler la puissance puis de nouveau
sur un pour le lancer puis sur deux pour
le rattrapp et encore même si tu as
compris ça de l'autre côté il faut que G
trud la ramasse le Frisbey et ça ben j'y
arrive
pas allez [ __ ] mais pourquoi il peut
pas se baisser c'est trop difficile
allez mais merde là salut passe devant
les mains même le gardien de soccer il
aurait rattrapé celle-là mais la
prochaine fois j'amènerai le chien lui
au moins il y arrive bon il y a bien un
mode d'entraînement dans ces jeux tu me
diras mais c'est exactement la même
chose que le mode normal il y a rien
d'expliqué je déteste California Games
en fait non je déteste tous les jeux de
sport mais surtout California Games
faudrait vraiment être complètement con
pour avoir acheté la
suite tu viens pas de dire ok ok j'ai
California Games 2 avec des mini jeux
comme pour le premier le seul point
positif de ce jeu c'est la page d'intro
oui je pourrais faire ça toute la
journée B allez on commence par le
bodyboard et là je crois qu'on a
l'épreuve de sport la plus stupide que
j'ai jamais vu dans un jeu vidéo le seul
truc qu'il faut faire c'est appuyer sur
bas pour faire des ronds et tu fais rien
d'autre il y a bien des figures des
combinaisons d'après le le livré mais
aucune ne marche la touche B1 B2 enfin
ok 1 et 2 je suppose que c'est une
touche de la manette mais B j'ai essayé
ça a pas l'air de correspondre à bas
est-ce que je dois tenter de violer ma
master système avec une manette de
Nintendo j'ai essayé toutes les
combinaisons possibles et aucune ne
marche alors quoi qu'est-ce qu'on est
censé faire et ben on fait des ronds
voilà c'est tout pendant toute l'épreuve
et jusqu'au moment où la vague disparaît
qu'il faut éviter des des des des truc
qui flotte à la surface attention le
plongeurs un tonneau un rocher il vient
tout ça pourquoi finalement pour rentrer
un record à la con qui sera passé dès
qu'on aura été à la console ou pour
faire la fête à la fin de l'épreuve avec
un vieux travelot
brésilien faut pas avoir le sens des
priorités
merde le snowboard maintenant je suppose
qu'il faut lâcher le mec sur la montagne
ou pas
ah génial encore un jeu d'obstacle à
éviter allez j'essaie même pas
suivant le delta
plan oh mais pitié mais tuez-moi le jeu
se ventait d'être à H joueurs mais
comment tu veux convaincre h personnes
de jouer à ce truc une personne à la
fois tu en a une qui joue et 7 qui se
font chier ça me rappelle les fameux
copains là qu'on a tous vous savez ceux
qui vous invité chez eux pour jouer à la
console et finalement il jou devant vous
et vous vous faisz chier derrière c'est
pareil je vais pas tous les faire je
pourrais aussi vous parler des Summer
Games ou de World Games avec des jeux
aussi intéressants que le lancé de Tron
d'arbre en Écosse ou la course sur des
rondin flottants avec des vieux
bûcherons canadien mais bon ça va la
boîte dit que c'est des sports de classe
mondiale donc ça va passons plutôt à un
jeu sur lequel tout le monde en a chier
track Enfield alors que vous avez
commencé sur la version nest la version
Sega ou la version PlayStation pour les
plus jeunes d'entre vous vous y avez
tous joué vous savez très bien pourquoi
je parle de ce jeu c'était le premier
jeu introduire la notion de masturbation
de manette où vous deviez appuyer comme
des bourrins sur A et B très rapidement
pour aller plus vite ah merde et voilà
tu as gagné le 100
m c'est la
maîtrise je
[Musique]
reviens non bras ah [ __ ] ça fait mal
je souffre le
marteour continue ça dirait tu dit cela
dit je me rappelle moi que ces jeux
c'était aussi l'occasion pour tout le
monde d'exposer ses techniques perso
pour gagner tout le monde avait plus ou
moins sa technique spéciale secrète pour
bouriner la manette il y avait la
technique de la table ça marchait pas il
y avait la technique du t-shirt ça
marchait pas non plus ou alors il y
avait la technique de coller la manette
entre ses cuisses mais il fallait pas
sortir ça du
contexte mais bon tout ça c'est trop
gentil c'est de la merde moi j'avais
inventé des vraies techniques agressives
qui marchait vraiment par exemple tu
pouvais mettre des PE petit coup de cou
à ton adversaire pour le déconcentrer tu
pouvais discrètement débrancher ou
piquer sa manette un grand classique
mais ça marche toujours
ou d'autres technique diverse qui
marchait aussi plutôt
bien moi ce qui me gonflait le plus dans
ces jeux c'était surtout qu'ils étaient
quasiment tous basés sur le même
principe en fait je veux dire est-ce
qu'ils ont vraiment testé leur jeu enfin
n'importe qui serait rendu compte que
passer la troisème épreuve un humain
normal a déjà une tendinite alors bon
avec les jeux suivants ils ont bien
rajouté des épreuves qui se jouaient
différemment j'ai jamais compris comment
ça fonctionnait meilleur moyen de faire
des points c'était encore tout
simplement
de et ça
marche d'ailleurs vous voulez savoir une
autre qualité fantastique de ces jeux
c'est que quand tu fais un championnat
si tu réussis toutes tes épreuves mais
que tu en rates une seule c'est fini
Game Over le jeu revient à l'écran titre
et tu as plus qu'à recommencer du début
et qui voudrait recommencer ce genre de
jeu enfin mais même dans le masocisme
mais il y a une part de plaisir là avec
les jeux comme ça c'est juste de la
souffrance à l'état pur et je préfère
accepter n'importe quoi plutôt que
continuer
ça bon écoutez vous avez gagné moi
j'abandonne ça c'est insupportable quoi
j'ai gagné quoi vous avez gagné votre
truc là écoute voilà ce que tu vas faire
non non non
[Musique]